So I think a lot about
the role of poetry.
What is poetry?
And I've come to the conclusion
that poetry is essentially
a technology of attention.
It's a magnifying glass.
It unveils in the full
meaning of the term.
It strips bare under a light
and shatters our indifference
to the everyday.
It awakens the ontological wow.
It makes us realize
that we are alive.
It italicizes experience.
The paragraph of subjectivity,
the narrator in our head.
It's being written, the
paragraph in real time.
It is the voice in
our head that lets
us know that we exist, becomes
emboldened and underlined.
When we read a poem,
the poem reads us.
It's a tool of illumination.
It's an altar.
It's something we surrender
to in hopes of leading us
towards the place of
radical exaltation.